foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where that is Dom cash is king and
the paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your calls about your life
and your money uh been a hot minute
since we were on here together both of
us traveling and working and traveling
and playing it's good to see you man
good to see you you're looking good
you're making you're getting handsomer
by the time oh that's that's true that's
definitely true oh brother I don't know
what are you even what have you been
doing while you were gone that's scary
we head out tomorrow to a sold out event
in Sacramento we've got the Building
Wealth live event tomorrow night with Dr
deloney and Rachel Cruz and George camo
and I and Ken Coleman and so we'll fly
out of here in the morning and head over
to California and do an event there
tomorrow night thank you Sacramento we
appreciate you rumor is they need us
Dave well rumor is every city we go to
needs us but some more than others but
there's no question about it so we're
excited a lot of good things happening
around here right now launch of the
gazelle debit card last week was
absolutely Mammoth and huge thank you
for all of you you that have already
gotten your gazelle debit card the smart
way the Ramsay way to spend and save
thank you for all of you that have
already signed up for the spring
smart conference the inaugural event at
the Ramsey Event Center which will be
completed by then it's sitting on the
hill behind me under construction and
will be done and ready to do events on
in the spring the inaugural event will
be in April
looking forward to that and April 14 and
15 really really excited about that so a
lot of good things there a lot of
tickets on that already sold most of the
VIP and platinums are already gone good
check all that out and the live events
are up for sale for spring most of them
anyway we've got a couple of them in
contract and you can check them all out
at
ramseysolutions.com let's start this
hour off with James in Billings Montana
hey James how are you
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than I deserve sir what's up in your
world okay well uh uh Billings is our
closest town I'm actually in Sheridan
Wyoming but that's neither here or there
uh the reason I called was my wife and I
are wanting to work with debt-free we've
been debt-free for a little over 10
years uh we're wanting to pay off our
the rest of our mortgage uh using some
funds from our retirement and annuities
accounts cool how old are you
I am 68. okay and how much money is in
the accounts
uh right now
well it's it's it's extremely down since
the first of the year right now it's uh
about 710 000 what's it take to pay off
your house no uh about 163
000. I woke up in your shoes I'd be dead
free house and everything but let's
close a business today my brother
okay well I just wanted to to bounce uh
bounce that off of you because let's
pretend you had 600 000 and not 750.
and you got a paid for house would you
go borrow money on your house to put it
into the stock market
no okay every day you don't pay it off
that's what you're doing
okay that makes sense to you
yes sir it does yeah you're gonna have
some taxes you're gonna have some taxes
on that so you're going to pull out more
you're probably going to pull out uh 200
so get get your Tax Advisor look at what
your taxes are going to be but obviously
there's no penalty because you're over
59 and a half but dude you've done a
wonderful job you're millionaires well
done so Dave what's the
I guess It ultimately becomes a Gamble
I my first instinct would be to say okay
let's let's go and do this but let's
wait six months to see if the interest
rates are going to drop back off
um but I guess that can be a Fool's
errand right I could I could end up
perpetually waiting right yeah yeah and
you don't know I mean so I I I think
stock market will be back up if that's
what you mean yeah I don't know if it
would be back up in six months it may be
it may be 12 I don't know but I'm I'm
not pulling money out of the stock
market because it's down I'm pulling
money out because I'm gonna be that free
I'm gonna pay the house off yeah period
and so if the market was up and booming
I would have given him the exact same
answer that's right yeah so we're always
going to lead you to
now if he had two hundred thousand
dollars to his name
that's his total nest egg and he's going
to be broke after he pays off the house
no I'm probably gonna I'm probably gonna
tap the brakes on that one okay because
I don't want to clean out the nest egg
that is one ratio I'm looking at okay
that's why I'm asking how much he had in
there but
he's got plenty left over he's gonna
have over 100 no liability is worth its
weight yeah and the piece that you have
when you don't have a house payment in
weird and wacky times yeah it's a
there's you know oh it's Halloween you
know what I mean the whole freaking year
has been Halloween right and uh and so I
mean the god there's goblins in DC
apparently and so you know um you know
the whole and everybody's like oh I'm
scared yeah well one way to not be
scared is
um no Dad don't know anybody yeah
changes everything Dawn Is With Us in
Detroit hey Don how are you hi thank you
gentlemen for taking my call sure what's
up I only have less than 10 years to be
investing and what do you mean when you
keep saying you need to stay in for the
Long Haul
with your Investments well a study that
I did several years ago and I've not
updated It In fairness but it's probably
fairly accurate still
I looked at uh all of the potential
consecutive five-year periods like 1955
to 1960 1956 to 1961 and so on all the
way up the calendar since the stock
market opened
97 at that time again I've not updated
this 97 of the five-year periods made
money
okay and so that told me if I leave it
alone five years I'm probably okay
and so when I say long term that's kind
of the minimum 67 percent
of the three-year periods made money
okay so two out of three times
you'd make money right right but that's
not that scares me when we talk about
the question the way you asked it if you
had a three-year window I'd be going you
know right now here's the other thing to
add to your equation though that
sometimes financial planners and the
like quit don't do is that let's say you
got a million dollars and you retire
10 years from today
okay it's not like you're gonna cash it
out that day
it's still going to be in the market you
may be taking off some of the earnings
to live on and to enjoy but it's not
like up 65 cleaner out that's not what
people do and so likely you're if you've
got 10 years of working life let's say
you're 55 and 65 is the 10-year Mark
you're likely going to leave this money
alone for 30 plus years
okay right because you're going to be
living off the interest you're not going
to just cash it in like I'm 62 I've
cashed nothing in I'm just going to let
it sit there and grow I'm living off of
I'll still work but
um I mean I'm living off of that but if
I was if I retired today uh I I've got
plenty of other Investments other than
the stock market that I wouldn't touch
wouldn't touch my retirement so my
retirement's probably not going to be
touched While I'm Alive
okay because I know there was a freeze
on my
um Investments for 33 years because I
was on disability with the company
and then I found out I could they sent a
letter to ask me if I wanted to roll
over go under their oh roll over
grandfather no roll over yeah if you can
get out of there get out of there for
sure and roll it over to an IRA no taxes
on it yeah that's very cool yeah but
long term is five years or more and keep
in mind you're probably not cashing it
in people when you get to 65 anyway like
the guy before he was 68 he's not
cashing that other money in just enough
to pay off his house the rest of it's
going to sit there he's probably living
off of nothing this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
for people of a certain age I love it
when they play your favorite songs Dave
for pop music
yeah well okay oh Dr John deloney number
one best-selling author Ramsey
personalities my co-host today open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five so the government is
planning to hand out more free money in
terms of forgiving student loans or so
we hear
what if that forgiveness doesn't wipe
out all your student loan debt
that means you're still in debt that
means they did not fix your problem or
your life
and that means you're going to have to
fix your problem in your life which by
the way the sooner you realize that the
better off you're going to be and the
quicker you're going to have a life
people who wait on Washington to give
them a life have a life that sucks
I mean think about a life brought to you
by the DMV there you go this is what
happens when you live by government
prosperity
socialism doesn't work so waiting on the
government to fix your student loan
debts a wish don't do this what I will
give you is a guarantee I will guarantee
you that millions of people literally
millions of people have paid off their
student loan debts as a result of going
through Financial Peace University
and
it's a proven plan to pay off all your
debt in just a couple of years not
decades not Millennials you just get it
done and then you get your life back and
you're able to be incredibly generous
and build wealth and do all kinds of
things when you don't have any stinking
payments including having evicted Miss
Sallie Mae so start Financial Peace
University right now go to
ramseysolutions.com FPU
kick Sallie Mae out ramseysolutions.com
FPU all right it looks like Matthew's in
Atlanta hi Matthew welcome to the Ramsay
show
Dave thanks for having me sure what's up
all right so
um I want to start off with
um a big fan of baby steps um I'm 24
years old
um currently just finished building a
house
um did a lot of the work myself with the
help of friends and family and was able
to build a house for under two hundred
thousand dollars in this crazy Market
we're in
um but basically I'm at a point with
that project kind of depleted my savings
but I'm starting to have some serious
truck troubles and I know you are
anti-car payment and I'm just trying to
figure out what I kind of need to start
preparing for because it's an old pickup
truck it's got almost 300 000 miles on
it and it leaks oil doesn't have AC it's
just uh
it's basically it needs these tires it
just needs a lot of stuff and it's not
it's probably needs more than the truck
is worth all of that was happening while
you were building the house
yes so why did it now become a dad gum
emergency
well I mean that was happening six
months ago it was leaking oil
yeah six months ago I had 298 000 miles
on it
mm-hmm
so I'm not going to give you permission
to turn it into drama now when you
didn't then
yeah okay what do you make a year
about thirty six thousand
okay
what other debts do you have
some debt to some family members to help
me kind of seal the deal with getting
the house finished in time
um because with all the material rate
increases how much do you owe your
family
uh right at fifty thousand and what's
this house worth about 300
uh no it appraised for five hundred
thousand way to go man congratulations
okay thank you
um
what do you do for a living to make 36
000 a year
local property management company doing
maintenance
um so basically we manage rental
properties and I
fix them when they break okay good for
you
okay two things I would do if I woke up
in your shoes
okay
I was pushing on you because of the the
change in the truck is not Material only
the change in your situation
although in other words the truck was
not a crisis before but it became a
crisis now that you finish the house and
you looked up and went oh crap look what
I did
yeah yeah and so uh and you go what if
this thing falls down on me well here's
the thing probably
you've got six months before the thing
lays down
okay but very likely you got three
months would you agree with that okay
yeah because it's just it's just you
just looked up and went this roof looks
bad it's probably going to leak but it's
not yet leaking and that's kind of what
we're doing here so that's the way I'm
analyzing this if I'm missing something
you can you can argue with me that's
okay
um okay the uh so what would I do in
your shoes man you you have a gift in
knowing how to work with your hands and
you can make a lot of money building
decks on the weekends or doing
maintenance handyman work for somebody
on the weekends and I'll bet you you
could pile up five or six thousand bucks
in two or three months side jobs
yeah and I I do have a woodworking
business that I'm kind of in the process
of starting up do you making money
I haven't made it I haven't turned a
profit yet okay I want you to go make
some money to buy it I don't I'm not I'm
not talking about your dreams I want you
to go make some money to buy a truck
okay like a five because you're driving
a two thousand dollar truck we need to
get you into a six or an eight thousand
dollar truck so you need five or six
grand
okay and you need that in the next 90
days and you need to get that as extra
income way to go
and this next truck is not going to be
pretty and people go your buddies in the
construction Trader gonna make fun of
you and you pull up to the seller they
already do though that's right and so
none of that's going to change my fear
is that you got a house now
and you started flexing your muscles a
little bit and you think guys and houses
should drive cars that look like X or Y
oh yeah and I don't want you to start
getting too big for your britches you
owe your family like the way you talked
about how you got into this house I did
it for two hundred thousand dollars and
then you quietly whispered and I had to
go ask Mommy for fifty thousand too
right so there's a little bit of flexing
and a little bit of reality let's do
this all the right way and let's work
like a maniac for the next 12 to 18 to
24 months pay off mom and dad
get yourself a truck that's that you can
rely on and build your business you're
worth more than thirty six thousand
dollars my friend with the skills you've
got yeah you need to be making more
money overall that's a that's a Ken
Coleman thing there but but as far as
what you called about as far as the
truck 90 days
two thousand dollars a month to sixty is
six grand sell the truck for two that's
an eight thousand dollar truck that's a
move up that's not a permanent solution
but that keeps you from being left on
the side of the road uh without anything
working you're probably gonna put some
tires on it in the meantime too uh you
know because you might blow a tire that
that's very real I don't know how bad
the tires are you gotta look at them but
if you can make it four months with the
tires because tires do not increase the
value of a two thousand dollar truck
yep so putting putting a thousand
dollars worth of tires on there doesn't
solve anything except except keep you
from being stranded so that that's what
I would do and the second thing I would
do is I would just run down to the
credit union if you can talk them into
it to loaning you fifty thousand on a
500 000 house fixed rate on a one-year
note and pay it off in one year and go
and pay off mom and dad a day yes
because Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you owe your relatives
money
the borrower is slave yes the lender and
it changes relationships and I wouldn't
want that even for a year if I were in
your shoes but if you don't have any
choices then you just do need to do what
John said and roll up your sleeves and
after you get the truck let's go and get
the the family loan cleared after that
so but uh great job 36 Grand sitting in
a half million dollar house almost paid
for he man he Dave he's on a precipice
he is right on that edge where 24 year
olds become 25 26 year olds and he can
look up and owe nobody anything and be a
millionaire and be a millionaire in
short order or he's can also have he
could fall backwards into normal a 2024
F-350 Dually and plus this and plus a
bunch of tools I was more on that than
he does on the house and be a in a mess
he's like he's sitting right on that
precipice man you can you can you could
fall off into stupid right here really
really easy man yeah there's it's from
two guys who did it right yeah this is
true and why did it involve trucks in
both of our cases both of our cases
yeah we know the type we look at them in
the mirror yeah oh there you go hey nice
call Matthew and overall man I got to
tell you this is pretty impressive 24
years old 50 000 old on five million 500
000 house very impressive very well done
sir but yeah John's right don't fall the
wrong way on this there's a lean up the
hill don't fall back
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Ricardo and Haley are with us
hey guys how are you doing great awesome
welcome good to have you guys where do
you guys live
Burlington Iowa awesome welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off we paid off 132
000 in 31 months good for you and hello
and what was your range of income during
that two and a half years well we went
from about probably 125 down to about 90
and finished out about 210. whoa what do
you all do for a living
um so I am partnered in a Jimmy John's
franchise and I oversee on restaurants
on a daily basis owner operator so you
know covid all that silliness all that
nonsense that put us down and then
things obviously really oh and so that's
why we go down to 90 and then back to
Japan so things are booming now yeah
very good very good over the last couple
years very good that's a great franchise
well done awesome thank you sir I
appreciate you saying that stuff good
stuff very cool very cool so what kind
of debt was 132 000. credit cards was a
lot of it a business loan for him
um a big obnoxious bed
um medical debt a big obnoxious bed yeah
yeah eight thousand dollar bed okay and
finance today yeah zero percent though
right yeah yeah okay it was a seven year
loan but uh we got seriously
the way you said that was like credit
cards business a bed I bought it before
her okay how long y'all been married
we've been married two years okay hey
you bought yourself an eight thousand
dollar bed yeah it wasn't a wise
decision most of my buddies still sleep
in sleeping bags man when I was single
John I did have just a box spring and a
mattress so
wow you love yourself more than I loved
myself honestly
good for you man thank you oh my gosh
wow so what happened what turned all
this around well you got married and
that that accelerated it in the middle
of it right sure yeah so um well you saw
his shirt
um my brother-in-law was a painting
about money actually is who turned us on
to you he went through the plan and he
was on maybe step four five six actually
completed step seven oh wow and then we
sort of half-butted it for a little bit
um in the beginning and still had credit
cards and then of July of 2020 my wife
was working at a car dealership and lost
her job from covid and we just were very
very low and we then Ramsey plus just
came out that summer and we signed up
for it and we did the FPU on zoom and uh
watched all the videos did that and it
just um got rid of the credit cards and
really ran our budget down sold
everything
Facebook Marketplace lots of that stuff
and sold most of my watch that's why
your income was going down and life
looked dark extremely dark yeah it was
the lowest it costs we could have been
at you know March of 2020 you weren't
sure the world wasn't over right right I
mean you even weren't right you know and
the restaurant business was still being
just pummeled by the government
regulations yep and it was hard to know
if I was going to have employees what
was going on somebody sneezes they can't
come to work for five days so I remember
yeah it was very very tough so but
um you know that's when Haley came in
and started working with me in the
business and that's that's what we do
together so oh good okay all right so
the heck with the car dealers we're
gonna get in the restaurant business
yeah exactly yeah I love it I love it we
make sandwiches how did that
conversation start did did you say hey
hey honey I can help or did you finally
say I'm crying Uncle I need help I kept
asking him I'm like I would not have to
go look for a job if I my husband gave
me one
like I know the business I can I can
come help I know how to make sandwiches
and there it is yeah yeah
Wow way to go guys I'm proud of y'all
well done how's it feel to be free it
feels amazing incredible it feels
incredible no just having cash in your
wallet like you said yeah when you don't
have debt you have money and it really
feels amazing
moving into our new house even this year
bought our new house cash flowed it
um we actually put a thing on the
Facebook page that a few years ago we
were over a hundred thousand dollars in
debt and didn't know what was going on
this year we were able to buy a new home
on a 15-year fixed uh mortgage with a
good down payment 20 percent
yep Ready To Roll life's awesome it's
every day I wake up and I just can't
believe how beautiful it is tell me
about
um be real specific people say like it
feels great um we've got peace what does
that actually mean for you two like what
is different now
it means I mean honestly we we still
talk to each other about finances but if
he goes and buys something that he needs
for work his shoes are 260 that he wears
to work but he's on his feet for 12
hours for most of the day so I mean it
is it's just fine so we just look at
each other like hey I bought new shoes
cool yeah that's fine one thing we
learned from Financial Peace was to set
that limit for couples of what the
threshold is and I'll actually tell a
quick story I once had a chip in my
windshield and I went to get it quoted
and so it was 400 so I said okay and do
it so I told Haley that night over
dinner and she goes are you kidding me I
said well I need a new windshield she
goes yeah but it's over the limit and
accountability yeah so what
what your business is taking off she
said if it's life or death make the call
then but just just text me first next
time yeah good for you good for you but
that's all practicing new communication
and it's teamwork practicing teamwork
that's right I love it we don't argue
about money ever no so it's been an
amazing feeling going into marriage and
just not even really caring or worrying
about money honestly yeah just being
intentional and you know knowing our
goals working together for it when you
pan back what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is lose a stupid
credit card all those credit card points
are the biggest scam you'll ever fall
for it is so crazy when we were doing
this when we first started we tried to
do it ramsay-ish and we tried to still
have a credit card and we actually got a
tax return and Haley said well we have
this this money from the stock Trader
we'll go ahead and pay off this one uh
you know bank loan and I said we can't
because we still have a credit card
payment to make this month and we need
to pay off that three thousand dollars
you put on the credit card last month so
I could get thirty dollars in points or
some nonsense and it was July 2020 when
we finally cut them up and before I was
authorizing we had like eight credit
cards it just completely out of hand in
my 20s and they're just I cannot
everyone out there listening I was back
there listening one day three years ago
and Dave was saying no credit cards and
I was laughing to myself in my car
saying you're just giving away free
money no you're not those people are
winning they're taking it from you stop
them use a debit card use cash take cash
to the grocery store if you need to
yep get your gazelle debit card that's
exactly right and guess what every
waiter or waitress you tip with cash is
way more happy than getting that stupid
number written down on the card because
they don't have to yeah yeah it keeps
branding out of it hey what uh one one
one quick side question
uh what's it like to have a
brother-in-law who is right
it's not yeah
he kind of got that right he's got it on
the back of his shirt he goes I'm the
bro I'm the brother-in-law with an
opinion but my line is always the broke
brother-in-law's opinion and he's on
baby step seven so he doesn't really
qualify and his advice was go get into
financial position law has been right a
few times in my 20 years and man it's
hard because he just knows right my
brother-in-law's smarter than me is a
better human than me and so it just I
feel it have you come to terms with that
yeah we're really blessed we have
amazing I have amazing brother and
sister-in-law they actually
um drove us down here and they said they
weren't going to miss it for anything
and they were there to cheer us on and
every time we paid something off we
would tell them and they were the first
call we made to screen with them when we
were debt free
good for you yeah
well done you gotta have people man
that's that's awesome very well done
good job you guys very cool well we've
got a copy of Total Money Makeover for
you to give away and Inspire someone
like he inspired you that time uh the
baby steps millionaires book which is
the latest number one bestseller on all
the millionaires we're seeing and that's
the next chapter in your all story you
are well on your way and of course a
Financial Peace University membership
for a year you've already been through
it you'll be able to give that away
absolutely and get somebody started in
the process so thank you guys thanks for
making the trip down here you're amazing
I'm so proud of you well well done good
stuff thank you Ricardo and Haley
Burlington Iowa 132
000 paid off in 31 months making 125 to
90 to 210. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
James it would be interesting to go back
and look how many of these Dead free
screams in the last two weeks have been
30 months I've seen a bunch of them I
had two in a row last week I remember
and so the year of covid I mean 30
months is January basically uh give or
take you know and so as you know the
year of covid they start out the year
normal and then the whole dad blame
World falls apart and then it didn't
fall apart and then you didn't die and
then we did flatten the curve but nobody
cared and then you went and got yourself
a life all because of this it's turned
out this well in a weird
backward ways ended up being a blessing
for a lot of people they got their lives
straightened out and I'll see you on
behalf of the country thanks for walking
the little storm and telling everybody
calm down I'll be okay here's a plan
take the next right step it's gonna be
okay gonna be okay we did that together
all of us here at Ramsey this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today robs weatherson
Philadelphia hey Rob what's up
hey Dave uh thanks for taking the call
sure it's very cool talking to you uh
big fan uh thank you let's see I'm uh uh
57 years old
um about a month away from my the end of
baby step two and that's not the nature
of my question I have um I have a
employer pension plan that is
terminating and they're offering me some
choices like
um an annuity that would pay five
minutes a month forever no or an 80 80
000 lump sum yeah
roll into a uh a company sponsored Ross
just roll it into an IRA in your own
name
in my own name yeah okay and put it on
put it into the types of mutual funds we
talk about growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
you'll make money well that's exactly my
second second question was if I would if
I would stick with those four absolutely
absolutely that's exactly what I would
do here's the thing when you have a
Company pension plan and you die it dies
when you die
right when you move the 80 000 into a
mutual fund it doesn't die when you die
it's in your name and it goes to your
estate to your heirs so you get more
money on death and by the way you're
going to make more money than that
annuity was going to pay you by being in
good mutual funds over the Long Haul I
mean you might not in the next 10
minutes we've got some economic
views we're dealing with right now and
um so there you go but yeah jump online
at ramseysolutions.com get with one of
the smartvestor pros they'll help you
get into those four mutual funds and
help you do the direct transfer rollover
so no taxes are withheld and you'll be
ready to go Garrett's in Atlanta hi
Garrett how are you
good thanks Dave for taking the call
sure appreciate it and we won't get into
the football game this Saturday so since
I'm in Atlanta
um I was just kidding
I was going to ignore it and let you go
we'll send you a condolences card next
week oh yeah yeah I hope I sure hope I
send you a condolences all right what's
up I love it um so I've read my wife and
I for the last 10 years and I would say
me probably have been on the uh
originally for about 10 years been on
the Ramsay light uh you know syndrome
um of the past two years we've done a
really good job of going through
financial peace and you know really
hitting it dead hard
um in the last year had a really good
um situation with my income as far as
I'm in sales so coming January 2023 I'm
gonna have to pretty significant bonus
from some really good accounts that I
landed last year so
um in looking at that we're going to be
able to pretty much wipe out most of the
debt that we have left in baby step two
besides the house
um and just trying to understand kind of
with another large chunk of money kind
of sitting there well congratulations
how much are you getting
uh should be probably pre-tax around 140
000 but good for you yeah so we'll see
what 100 Grand clearer then and you'll
be able to do some stuff how much debt
have you got not counting your house
because you said most of sort of kind of
so I don't know what you're talking
about yeah it's around basically
probably a little over thirty thousand
dollars so um 100 debt free
nothing but the house if you're at a 30
000 check
correct okay all right so why most of
them so why the most stuff sort of kind
of language then
well I guess there's some things
obviously my wife and I have
communicated and talked about maybe
wanting to do which is potentially a
small little cash house upgrade right
paint the house kind of patio small
small okay but that's purchases that's
not debt right and so I really being in
being in sales I want to make sure that
I'm comfortable when you call it three
to six months I feel like this
commission as you know can go up and
down not it's not three to six months of
income it's three to six months of
expenses
okay right expenses don't go up and down
and then obviously what account to put
it in you always say money market is up
still the best option right now
considering the economy and everything
so you're not you're not trying to make
money with the emergency fund you're
trying to protect the things that are
making money
great and I I guess I need to get on my
Smart investor Pro because I need to
find somebody with a good mutual fund
situation so I'm sure you have a few of
those yeah just jump online and do that
but here's the thing you just here's
what I had to learn to do the first time
I got to check that size it's kind of
mind-blowing and our human tendency is
okay I'm gonna have a hundred thousand
so we in our mind we kind of spend 300
000. oh man right or 800 000 if you're
in the baloney house right and so you
got to back down and just go okay I'm
gonna take I'm gonna write down the
number 100. I'm gonna take 30 out of it
and I'm 100 debt free I'm gonna take 25
out of it and I'm gonna have an
emergency fund and then I'm going to
allocate for home repairs actual home
repairs and actual bids and we're not
going to accidentally take on more home
repairs than we have money
because I put you back in debt
okay but you need your emergency fund in
place and debt free and I'll call it 25
I just made that number up I don't care
what it is but that's 55 which leaves
you 45 and the kitchen and the painting
is 25 okay and so now I've still got 20
and I can you know start some investing
for the kids college and some stuff like
that then with that and we get to fix up
the house and we paid off all the debt
and we have the emergency fund all in
one Fell Swoop but if you don't freaking
write it down
it'll blow up on you
understood and if a GC knows you have I
don't know around fifty thousand dollars
to spend they're gonna put a hundred
thousand dollar bid in front of you and
make it really hard to walk away from
yeah because there's a lot of stuff you
can do to a kitchen these days yes and
let me let me challenge you one more
take ten thousand of that off top and
give it away
oh definitely give some of that money
away I'll be tithing for sure um and
giving let that be a spirit of
um first fruits man yeah generosity the
whole process hey Dave help me with this
real quick
um we don't have very much time
in in a minute help me understand what
is happening with the economy because it
feels like people are still hiring
businesses are still making money and
that I don't fully understand but the
fed's trying to crash it yeah they're
trying to run it up against the wall and
I don't understand that well because
you're a logical human oh no one's ever
said that whatever yeah like if it feels
like they're trying to run it into a
bridge and shut out loud they want to
cause unemployment
help me help me understand even the
concept the concept is is if we slow the
economy down because of unemployment
then the prices will stop going up it's
squat it's in an effort to squash
inflation the problem is that's not what
caused inflation right the Speedy
economy isn't what caused inflation it
was horrible domestic policy on oil turn
the spigot off the prices go up no
kidding okay so uh Biden sticker I did
that for sure the other parts of
inflation were coveted related not code
related they're quarantine just a lag
they're quarantine related you shut down
the factories on cars
there's no cars so the price of cars
goes way up you shut down the factory on
producing Lumber there's no Lumber so
the price of lumber goes up oh wait now
we started the factory specs so now
there's cars again now there's Lumber
again it's starting to smooth out
Lumber's back down that's what it means
if you wait a hot minute if you wait a
hot minute and quit screwing around with
it trying to fix it with the wrong tool
quit using a hammer on a Phillips screw
I mean really and that's the problem and
that's why everybody's so pissed off
even Bernie Sanders came out and said
this is the wrong thing it's yeah well
me and Bernie Sanders agreed on
something yeah I know I felt my feet
getting cold
Dave and Bernie agree about something
well twice in six months we agreed about
I'm not near as smart economically but I
remember at the start of deer season
last year the shelves in the ammo
department and at Academy was wiped out
and then I went there the other day and
they are full top to bottom and my first
thought was the factories must be
catching up and then I thought well what
maybe I'm missing something but why are
they trying to drive this thing there's
two things that cause was precious to go
through the roof okay two potential
things that we're discussing here anyway
one type of inflation is what we had in
the 70s it was just a white hot economy
everything kept going up and everybody
got away with it and so it went up again
then it went up again then it went up
again it was just Prosperity heaped on
top of prosperity mix in a little greed
and boom okay and that's there was a
monetary policy in those days in the
late 70s early 80s very similar to this
George Volkert was have the FED back
then and um I was actually an adult and
remember this but you know and so they
did the same thing they just jacked
rates up to freeze to slow down the
economy but that econ that inflation in
the 70s was a different kind of
inflation this inflation was was
domestic oil production related and
quarantine Supply demand curve related
gotcha and if they'll if they'd leave it
alone they're gonna mess it up further
that's what it feels like when I keep
opening it up first my briskets Yeah the
more I open the grill the more I screw
it up if I just leave it alone exactly
if you just let it cook let it cook
it'll turn out but
we're trying to get people elected next
week so there you go this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where that is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality and host of
the Dr John deloney podcast which is um
quite frankly exploding in listenership
thank you guys for joining him on that
it is an incredible podcast they do a
great job also number one best-selling
author and Ramsay personality is my
co-host today Greg is going to start
this hour he is with us in Indianapolis
hi Greg welcome to the Ramsay show
hey gentlemen how are you doing better
than we deserve sir what's up in your
world
well
um my mother has just received a medical
malpractice uh settlement of about a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
uh my father is a degenerate gambler
we've been trying to explore ways that
we could uh somehow legally uh keep this
money so that it can last her for
hopefully the rest of her life and to do
it legally uh where he can't get a hold
of it and I was wondering what your
advice might be
is she still in relationship with him is
she still married
uh she is we've also explored that route
and it seems like it's it's going to
stay that way uh so I I don't believe
that that easiest most sensible option
is going to be an option
I'm sure Dave and I can come up with
some ideas about trusts and things like
that you're running into what I think is
one of the hardest things that we have
to deal with as finite beings which is
wanting something for somebody else
wanting healing or safety for somebody
else who for a host of reasons
does not choose that for themselves
absolutely absolutely it's power it's a
powerless feeling when you watch
somebody you love stay in a relationship
that's not safe it's powerless when you
someone gets a like this gets a a ticket
out and they choose to stay in right
it's tough tough tough tough
um yeah especially mother and father oh
gosh Polar Opposites in this situation
it's it's pretty bad even if you like
even if she Drew up a trust it
immediately gave you the money gave it
like whatever
is she going to be able to keep herself
from asking for it back or for cashing
it out and giving him a little bit here
and a little bit there
uh I think she will um she's pretty much
agreed uh that she's willing to put it
in my name
how long is this dysfunctional
relationship been going on
um
well maybe forever uh I I didn't take
notice until probably about six or seven
years ago maybe
she's a completely codependent enabler
the chances of her telling him no
over the next decade are close to zero
you're correct yeah she's gonna have to
give you the money to give it away to
her kids well and then you're going to
be the evil
son when she comes to you and wants her
money
well I mean all I'm really concerned
about is uh the legality of it I don't
want to step over the law as far as her
being him being her spouse and him
having any rights to it yeah and I also
don't want something to happen to her
and
uh he gets to end his life and in that
way you know yep yep so um you would
have to speak with some attorneys in
your state are they in Indiana
yes okay you'd have to speak with some
attorneys in Indiana to get some legal
advice on how to properly do this and
what the divorce laws are in most States
Most states
from my little bit of understanding of
the law and I'm not an attorney
say that when you are married half of
what you have is his and half of a
church
and it really doesn't really matter
where you put it at that point as a
matter of fact if he if she gave it all
to you the courts might go she gave it
all to you and half of it was his
and make you give it to him in the event
of a divorce okay
um and so uh if there's if there's a
trust and she's the beneficiary of the
trust and you are the trustee
um he might have marital rights to that
trust I don't know but uh in most I'm
amazed at uh the one of the few things
would be like if um if she brought this
money into the marriage then they might
protect it but it was all they were
already married when she got the money
and in Most states the law was going to
give him access to half of it and undo
almost anything you try to do
okay the only thing that will actually
protect her is divorce
and so the the problem is this
they have uh so much bigger problem
mathematically
than 125 thousand dollars
sure and uh so the the the only
the best news of this is it's making her
face
this yet again in a more real way and in
a way that puts some weight on it
for her to have to actually think about
how screwed up this situation is and so
um I'm so sad for all of you it's just
heartbreaking
um but I you know meet with an estate
attorney and see if under the laws of
Indiana if there's a way you can keep
his hands off of it by moving it around
somewhere into a trust or into your name
or whatever
um I mean she can gift it to you but I
think the gift could be undone in a
divorce court in most States
have you understand
um I'm assuming that the way you talked
about your old man that this is the ship
has sailed but
is there something to be to be said for
sitting down with him and saying this is
not for you this is to keep you all
alive for the next 15 years
uh this type of thing has been tried and
uh yeah my dad's always kind of been an
honorable man but this has completely uh
erased all of that yeah
um
addictions turns people into liars and
manipulators
absolutely
um but being able to tell her that this
advice came straight from Dave and John
will be great okay and uh I I appreciate
you guys uh telling me what you think
about it um well I'm sorry I think the
the only way I can
to my knowledge of of 30 years being in
the financial planning world to my
knowledge in Most states with the way
divorce law works as I understand it
again I want you to you're welcome to
double check the legality of this
because I could be wrong okay but I
don't think I am to my knowledge the
only way to protect this money is a
divorce and the divorce court likely
would say protecting half of it right it
might be protecting half of it but it
might say hey this was awarded to her
recently he has this situation but if
you wait five years they're not gonna do
that that's right okay so if you you
know I think that would protect it
probably but I'm not even sure then and
Greg you have to come to terms with the
fact that you can't want her to be well
more than she wants to be well yeah um I
mean you could want it but it's not
going to affect that change and at some
point you've got to open your hands here
because you're going to put yourself in
an early grave trying to get somebody
else to change their life which you
can't do she thinks she's being
kind by going along with all this and
she's being unkind to everyone involved
her self-inclusion exactly this is the
Ramsey Show
gazelle was made for you the never
quitting non-stopping gazelle intents
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
here in the back I have taken your
records and are playing them all today
it's bad it's bad the spring Ramsay's
looking forward to a lot of firsts and
we're pretty excited about it for the
first time ever we're hosting a smart
conference weekend right here in
Nashville a Nashville weekend and this
will be the very first event we host at
the new Ramsey Events Center we're
making Ramsay history with this event
how cool is that smart conference has
always been our biggest and best event
we have here at Ramsey the smart
conference weekend will be two days of
jam-packed blowout event where all the
Ramsay personalities teach on all the
different areas of your life me and
Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman on Career George
Campbell on money Dr John deloney on
relationships Christina Ellis we're
going to cover every area of your life
and because we're in Nashville uh well
there might be some music people popping
in you just never know if one of my
buddies is going to come around one of
these things and so and you're going to
get a commemorative event badge and pass
to celebrate the opening because you
were there at the very first Ramsey
Event Center event and here's the thing
very limited tickets for this event
usually
the smart conference is six to eight
thousand people our Event Center holds
2500. 2400 actually so uh Platinum
tickets sold out like the first day we
launched this
uh there's a few other upgrade VIP
tickets left they're going really fast
tickets start at 79 and that's the early
bird special you need to get yours right
now before they're gone here's the
details April 14th and 15th a Friday
night and a Saturday you can come in
early on Friday watch us do the show we
do it from one to four Central Time on
the glass there's always 52 a couple
hundred folks sitting out here watching
us including right now so uh just come
to the Ramsey Events Center in Nashville
make plans right now go to
ramseysolutions.com events get your
tickets right now and you'll be ready to
go our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you miss measure or you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping new
promos all the time always use the promo
code Ramsay and you'll get extra
discounts all right today's question
comes from Wesley in Arizona
I've been hearing oh man anytime
somebody starts with having here and oh
here we go I earn more and more in the
news recently about the government
looking at digital currency
are they doing away with cash and if so
should I be worried some are suggesting
taking money out of the bank and
investing it in gold or silver
that's not something I feel comfortable
with but I don't want to lose my money
hmm
they're coming for us Dave
you got a little prepper down inside of
you oh way down in there I'm worried
about some and I've been hearing
yeah they're coming for us they said and
I heard or a really crummy financial
planning firm
um especially when you're getting it off
the internet because everything on the
internet is true Abraham Lincoln said
that so um
okay
um
first let's understand
that actual
paper money
is a very small percentage of our
economy already
that when you venmo someone when you
write a check to someone when you use
your debit card to someone
when you have an automatic withdrawal
from your checking account to someone
100 of the money that transferred was
digital money you've never written me an
actual check Dave it just deposits in my
account right yeah all of my payroll is
not done with real money it's done with
digital money
[Music]
cue the UFO music okay so um dude we're
already I don't know what the percentage
is but what would you guess I mean what
percentage of our economy is paper money
and what percent of digital transfers as
we just discussed just guessing I'd say
95 at least yeah really high in the high
90s it's got to be our our digital
transfers here's what I know I recently
bought some concert tickets for like a
bunch of us and I had everybody pay me
back I still don't understand how to get
venmo from venmo into my checking
account so I said hey you guys got to
bring me checks and you I might as well
say hey I want you all to all um just
wear your bathing suits over to my house
for dinner like it was this they looked
at me like I was from Mars and they all
wrote checks and they were all written
in like like they'd written with their
feet like they didn't know how to do it
like little children wrote the check
yeah and Sheila was like man I don't
know how you have a friend did they
graduate from
Wesley you and me brother we can uh we
could count our silver coins when it all
goes down the woods so
um really my point is to do away with
cash and coins would really not
uh disrupt most of the economy most
people most of the time most people most
of the time I mean I I was in the gas
station the other day and a guy bought a
pack of gum with his debit card and I'm
like really you don't have a dollar I
mean you don't have two dollars I mean
he because people just I mean especially
depending on your age group right old
fart like me I've always got a couple
hundred dollar bills I got a redneck
emergency fund there's always thousand
thousand dollars a thousand dollars and
hundreds tucked somewhere in my clothing
right but the uh uh oh my gosh but the
yeah but young people they're just like
oh It's All Digital so we're not making
fun of you we're just pointing out the
digital is already a very much a way of
life and so don't panic and no there's
no credible indicators that the
government is going to do away with
paper money I think this was there is
some incredible indicators are going to
go away with a penny because it costs
more than a penny to make one right and
man it does literally they're losing
money producing pennies that nobody uses
correct you know and so
um you know so we probably are going to
see some of that but there's some
discussion about
um digital currencies and I think this
when the when the Bitcoin thing went
crazy those who were deep in all new
it's going to go bankrupt it's the
technology that's going to be cool down
the road yeah the technology is probably
going to end up usable fine that's I
mean all just like I imagine there was a
hubbub when they quit when the debit
card came out and then direct deposit
came out and I I think there's always a
lag on that kind of technology and it is
what it is and there should have been a
hubbub when the IRS had the unbelievable
genius move to withhold your taxes from
your check before you over got your
check
that was genius yes that got that
created a whole country of sheep yep and
because I got to tell you people if
y'all had to go line up somewhere and
hand hundred dollar bills to someone
called a tax collector for your taxes
out of your check every week there would
be a revolution oh baby it would be
there would be like pitchforks and burn
the monster
I mean it would be you know torches can
you imagine oh I that's but that's how
genius this transfer idea is hey we'll
take care we got you yeah it's a low
friction we're going to make this easy
for you to pay your taxes and then you
can just go to sleep and we will take
all your money well I remember during
covid when they said hey we'll just
deposit it for you yeah and I thought oh
if they can just put it in there they
can just take it out of there oh there
you go paranoia oh yeah there you go
yeah I told you there's a prepper down
in there oh he's way down in there but
he's there but hey uh and I've talked
about this on the show before uh Wesley
for those of you thinking about
investing in gold or silver
here's the reality um and this comes
from a great quote from one of my
closest buddies who works in banking
there in Texas
if it actually all goes down
if we are if if we are trading coffee
and bullets
we have this idea that our lives are
going to go on as they are like we're
going to go to the gas station in our
car on the way to our jobs and we're
going to hand a canister of bullets and
coffee in exchange for the gas
if we get there where we are trading
gold coins yep your neighbor will have
already shot you for your water and you
will have already like you're eating
pets like everything is different at
this point and so we stop falling for
the you know what when it all goes down
you're going to want to trade gold
bullion for your for what it's not it's
not going to work that way there's no
failed economy in the history since the
Roman Empire that has used gold as a
method of exchange
[Music]
because of a failed economy no never
once and if they find out you got it
once they'll come get it not once no
that's not the Hedge know your neighbors
that's the mechanic ash some new blue
jeans bullets and coffee yeah those are
the that's the barter economy is what
happens in a failed economy and then a
new regime comes up and they create new
paper money with their face on it this
is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
your small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the dad freeze stage Jerry
and Ellen are with us hey guys how are
you doing good doing good Dave good to
have you guys where do you live Round
Lake Heights Illinois okay and that's
near Waukegan Illinois ah okay cool good
to have you guys how much data have you
paid off well we paid off about 126
199.28 cents just about just about yeah
just about and how long did this take
took us about 36 months good for you and
your range of income during that time uh
we started at about 135 went to about 60
and then now we're up to 185. whoa what
do you all do for a living I.T both of
you both of us I do support he does
programming okay so did somebody lose a
job then you got it back is that what
happened that was me okay all right cool
well well done you guys are making good
money what kind of debt was the 126 000.
well you'd call this pretty much normal
except we didn't have any student loans
at the time we had uh about twenty four
thousand dollars between two vehicles we
had I want to say it was uh
30 000 in
in 30 or 36 000 in credit card credit
cards alone plus we had a second
mortgage which had come from refinancing
credit cards back in 2006 and we had a
lot of other and then during our debt
free stage during our debt free Journey
we actually paid off Thirty one thousand
dollars that we cash load in other
expenses oh wow including uh some some
money to the KGB some money to uh paying
off some uh medical bills some pet pet
medical medical bills as well as furnace
repairs and water water heaters okay so
how long you two been married about 34
years so what happened three years ago
after 30 years of marriage that you said
ah this needs to change okay this is
two-part
um the first thing that happened was in
July of 2018
I was afraid to take my dog to the vet
we didn't have any money we were broke I
was unemployed at the time
it turned out that my little brown dog
that's in the photo there had cancer and
it filled completely his chest before we
finally took I took we finally took him
to the vet and he couldn't breathe
then about a month later and I'm still
looking for a job I just
was going to start in a couple weeks we
got a call from the electric company
saying they're going to cut off our
electricity so the two things together
my guilt over that
I started looking for answers I had
heard of you Dave through silent Sales
Machine group and I was I had heard of
your book and entree leadership I was
selling on eBay I was selling on Amazon
I was selling on Etsy at the time
um what we ended up doing uh I had no
clue what I was doing financially with
business let's just put it that way
um
we ended up I ended up saying when we
started I started looking and I
remembered your book
and then I started looking into the
other stuff that you did I knew there
was a financial thing behind it once I
had an idea
about it and had the podcast and
everything I turned to Jerry and said
can we do this
and your answer was it's about time
where have you been all my life
beautiful I didn't really grow up with
the Ramsay process but my parents pretty
much lived that style as far as I knew
they didn't have a credit card to their
name but they they paid off their
mortgage and everything and you know we
were kind of an odd statistic because we
actually did have student loans but we
had paid them off about a decade before
we started the process my parents
actually had paid off their home they I
I was I was born and raised in the house
and lived in that house all the way up
until so you guys rolled out the whole
Ramsey process and started rolling and
started just doing it straight up just
straight up everything we said you did
it it was it was things 2020 really
really oh yeah I was in the hospital
between six and eight times that year
2021 I was in the hospital twice this
year blessedly I've been in once but
there was a very good reason I would say
it this time oh my God so I have
pulmonary hypertension oh wow so I'm
very susceptible to a lot of things and
I covered was Nash for you yeah covet is
still nasty for me yeah let's just put
it that way oh my goodness wow wow oh
bless your heart very cool I'm so glad
you got free of this that's got to help
with the hypertension well not only that
but as soon as we paid it off on July
4th of this year
my whole attitude toward buying things
changed a lot of people say in the
beginning they're buying attitude
I started reducing how much I was
spending on groceries I started really
looking at do I really need this I
wasn't willing to do that until we paid
it off wow I don't know why it took me
so long but I don't care now you're
there we're there yeah how's it feel to
be free
like quite a bit relaxing yes
[Laughter]
brother you look you are nine Xanax into
this day man you are just chill as could
be I love it
I love it oh it's amazing guys what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
the budget the budget is key we I never
understood a budget at all completely I
have a degree in geology I have a
master's degree in geology I am not a
non-science person I had no clue about
budgets
it's a different kind of math yes it is
because it's a math of the heart and
that's different than a simple equation
how has this helped your marriage
you can't even describe it we can't even
begin to describe how much we have
gotten together yeah how much that with
a lot of help from others have say hey
why are you talking about yourself in
the third person all the time
I was so disconnected from myself
and between this a person in Minnesota
who's adjusted me looking to Dana K
white's books which are on decluttering
and getting a new counselor wow it's
just completely true were you kind of
hoarding also yeah you think oh wow I
didn't know do you think it is like
boxes empty boxes oh my gosh you
collected empty boxes okay
hoarding yeah and actually I'm running a
business now and I'm looking at I'm like
we don't need all these boxes I'll get
this thing out of here all right there's
a lot of stuff cleaning up oh yeah so
proud of y'all well done thank you you
faced the person in the mirror and
that's the hardest one to face yes it is
very well done very well done and you
are free yeah we got a copy of uh Total
Money Makeover for you to give away to
somebody and get them started uh baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story as well uh
learn how to be a millionaire because
you're going to be one uh probably when
you just saw all that stuff but yeah
and uh of course Financial Peace
University a one-year membership to that
as well that's the live and give bundle
and we're going to help you guys you'll
be able to give and live and way to go
I'm so proud of you very very very well
done very well done all right what do
you tell people the absolute key is to
getting out of debt one more time the
budget the budget the budget is
the budget That's it man that's how we
do it right there and if you're
listening you you don't have the the
blessing of seeing Jerry and Ellen y'all
look like two people who have just flat
out arrived you look like you are
peaceful your accountants yes like just
everything about it man and if if
sometimes I talk to folks and they're
about to cry because they've got so much
buried in
I feel like you're about to cry out of
Joy just you are so glad that you're
still here right and you are free air
conditioner went out right after we paid
off everything and we looked at each
other and said
we'll put another window we'll put it a
couple window air conditioners in and
we'll save up the money delays baby step
three but we'll get a new HVAC system
there you go awesome there you go that's
a totally new life it's changed the new
sense of control and Destiny Jerry and
Ellen from Illinois
126 paid off in 36 months 135 to 60 to
185 counted down let's hear a debt-free
scream three three two one
[Applause]
I love it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey if you like this show please
consider subscribing to it on YouTube or
on the podcast we'd love for you to do
that we're offered on every podcast
platform that's out there from Spotify
to Apple to Google play whatever you can
find us everywhere also while you're
doing that leave us a review especially
if it's a five star don't bother if it's
one we just not hear from you
send those to James Charles and here's
the thing most importantly share the
show just take a link of it or just or
just tell your friend listen on the
radio station that you're listening on
wherever that is and uh just tell people
to spread the word because common sense
is so rare in America today that it's
like having a superpower so and I found
out if you if you subscribe if you leave
a five-star review it kicks it up in the
algorithms and you actually share the
show and it cost you nothing right it
puts it
you're helping America that's right I
mean really because I mean this this
information is important spread the word
not because I'm saying it but it's just
it's life-changing stuff we hear it here
every day Amy's with us Amy's in Boston
hi Amy how are you
hi there I'm doing well thank you so
much for taking my call I'm pretty
nervous here no troubles what's up
um yeah so my husband and I are on baby
stuff too
um we are both 52 years old
um so we got a little bit of a late
start
um we have paid off like a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars since the
beginning of 2020. very good
um yeah but like 76 or so thousand of
that has just been since um in the last
18 months or so
um so we are plugging along plugging
along
um and my question is and I I've heard
you guys answer this a similar version
of this question but
what do you do when you're not fully
fully on the same page with your spouse
with regard to How Deeply you're willing
to sacrifice like we're mostly on the
same page and like I said you know we're
making great progress but we have like
32 000 left
um and
my husband and I had a little situation
with the heat at our house because oil
is like over five dollars a gallon
so I was keeping the heat turned off
um and he was away on a work trip and he
turned the heat on and he was like
I'm sorry I am not you know I'm not
willing to wear a coat and a hat in my
house
um and
so I just I'm so stressed about heating
season
amen and how like we can afford it Amy
yes what's your household income
your husband's right
okay Amy this is not about I'm not I'm
not wearing listen I teach intensity
and the the depth of your sacrifice
will be based on the depth of your
intensity
and the depth of all of that is going to
be based on the depth of your why and uh
you're you're talking to Mr get
everybody out of debt Dave Ramsey and I
am not going to wear a coat in my house
I felt like he was being a drama queen
he's cold you are
Amy there's something below this what is
it there's something beneath this this
is not about heat what is it
have you been carrying a lot of this are
you scared
well are you tired
I'm definitely tired I'm definitely
tired
um
and like I am clearly the nerd in the
relationship if you guys couldn't tell
yeah yeah loud and clear and I'm high
intensity he is the Yes man he is you
know the free spirit for sure
and but he's been going along with you
pretty good because you paid off 76 000
in the last 18 months yeah
it's the line when you cut when you made
the man cold
hey Amy listen listen
okay Andy listen you ever been driving
down the highway and you got to go to
the bathroom and you you don't know when
the next exit is and so your body just
kind of settles into like a constant
like I gotta go but I'm fine and then
you exit and you get right to the gas
station and all of a sudden your body's
like it's happening right now and you
have to Sprint that last 15 feet into
the into the gas station for the last 15
miles you've been okay that's right
right that's where you are you are
several years into this you see the
Finish Line your 30 grand away you're
almost there
don't lose your marriage over a couple
hundred bucks I'm so pissed at Biden for
the oil prices yeah yeah don't yeah turn
the news off
like yes it's it's heat it's it's heat
it is what it is and it's just I praise
the lord we can afford it here's the
other thing I'll tell you this what this
means is there's a shirt there's every
marriage book I've ever read says that
you have a healthy marriage if you argue
about the thermostat
every every couple I've ever met in my
life argues about the thermostat me and
my wife are going to be married I've
been married 40 years and I still can't
convince Sharon how a thermostat works
that its purpose is just to hold the
temperature she thinks if she cranks it
up or down it makes it go faster I'm
like this isn't we got through the worst
of it the temperature
stop whining and then my husband comes
home from a chip and he's like I am not
wearing a coat and hat in my house he's
right he's right you know and the good
news is you're you're
uh you know he's willing to say that and
not just go crazy on you and you're
willing to laugh about it when we poke a
little fun at you because we've all done
stuff just exactly like you're doing and
like he's doing for that matter but you
really have done a great job so far and
you really are going to get there you're
almost and you really don't have to skip
a meal to do it
and oh my gosh I feel I'm I'm so
grateful for the encouragement and you
really don't have to live in a cold
house how many more months away you I
know you've got it you've already got
that number tattooed on your wrist how
soon
probably
seven to eight months yeah or less
alcohol is like when our when our fourth
kid graduates from high school it's like
I wanted by then five months I think
you're gonna do it in five months you
can do it you're there's other things
are gonna happen but the what the weird
thing is the math works better when
you're working together versus when
you've sacrificed so much that you lost
your partner and you lost the
connectivity and the unity of the
relationship that somehow causes the
math to get better more so than
alienating them over the temperature in
the in the house or whatever the thing
is you know so uh now you know if it was
if it was something else it was like I
demand to go out to eat I would tell him
to quit being a drama queen I demand to
go on vacation I deserve a vacation I
say shut up you whining snowflake I
would I would have got after him right
but but you know but all the men wanted
was Heat
what was the temperature
it was 52. good job
hey and you haven't told us the truth
you took the toilet paper out of the
house too already didn't you
oh guys we got through the worst of it
oh the kids are called too yeah she's
got a senior in high school it's going
to be telling his counselor when he's 42
that his mother actually froze him to
death while his dad was out of town on
behalf of mental health practitioners of
America we want to thank you for keeping
us in business for the next 30 Years
man that's so precious what's precious
is is not the situation but how she's
handling it yes hey and how he's
handling it like I say their marriage
clearly
um he's he was able to get up into the
line he's walked alongside with her for
three years he's he's put the work in
and he's also able to speak his needs
out loud which a lot of men won't do
they just live in resentment and anger
and they go to the bar and complain
about their wife hey good for you man
good for you I've got y'all got a
healthy marriage that's good yeah
thermostat Wars are a way of life
just it's just part of it turn it up
turn it down I got up yesterday morning
she's got it cranked down just because
she likes cold house not because she's
trying to save money yeah she just wants
to freeze me out
my wife would love to take up residence
on the Sun
just wants to live on the sun and I
don't understand it
don't understand it
[Music]
or the Ramsey Show in the books
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're that is Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality host of the
Dr John deloney show where they talk
about relationships and mental Wellness
every day you can check it out as a
podcast it is very popular he's also
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today Shelley's going to start
this hour off in Kansas City hi Shelly
how are you
yes hi so glad to talk to you about you
too um I have a question I am trying to
downsize my home and I'm not sure if I
should buy or sell first and I don't
want to get into a bad financial
situation so I was wondering what your
opinion is on that
well I've noticed that the real estate
market has slowed down have you noticed
that
yes definitely okay and what that means
to me is if you were to buy another
house and then it took two years to sell
yours that could put you in a pinch
yes understood so I'm gonna sell yours
first
and then I'm going to buy another one or
I'm going to go rent somewhere until I
buy another one one of the two it might
entail a double move it might entail
doing something we used to do back
before real estate went crazy white hot
because we used to do a contingency I
will sell mine to you contingent upon me
being able to find one in the next 30
days
okay so they can write uh Clause into
the contract all right anything you want
to in a contract if you can get them to
do it
okay
um I've got a family member who sold
their house with with cash recently and
in the contract they are renting it back
from the buyer for 60 days that gives
them time to get moved into their new
place and so they've actually sold the
house and now they're renting it for
like a dollar a month it was just
written into the deal
um so there's a bunch of different ways
you can do that I actually did that I
ran in mine back for almost three months
uh last year oh your the other house
yeah when I sold the big house yeah on
the hill and uh okay okay so whether
amount of time would you suggest knowing
that I need to go out and look and find
somewhere else I mean can you go as long
as you rent it back for six months and
whatever you can talk somebody into
whatever I can get the whatever you can
get somebody to do you know now here's
the thing the more crap you put on it
the harder it is to sell your house
right
so so what we did what we did in our
case was we went and uh were already
shopping before our sold we looked at
other properties we went and viewed
homes we looked at neighborhoods we
decided okay we're going to move to this
neighborhood and here's three houses on
the market I buy this one tomorrow if
ourselves and when I was sold that one
was gone
but there was another one that popped up
that was pretty similar and we jumped
into Ed and it made a good deal and it
was just fine so kind of have it
narrowed down the type of thing and the
area and it might even be that the house
you look at today is still on the market
when you get ready to buy the one you
pick out and then it could be fairly
simple and you would go oh you know I'll
be gone and as soon as that seller is
gone the only reason we had to stay in
our old one a little bit longer was it
wasn't because we didn't find the other
one it was because the guy that we
bought it from wanted to stay
so it was like a chain reaction thing he
wanted to stay so we had to stay and the
buyer buying mine didn't need it right
then so it worked out perfectly but uh
again that was that was uh 2020. it was
a different where 2021 it was a
different world but yeah uh crazy stuff
out there yeah the uh um yeah you can
anything you can talk somebody into but
what I would do is go ahead and select
where you want to be Jamie's with us
Jamie's in Indianapolis hi Jamie welcome
to the Ramsey Show
thank you hello how are you better than
I deserve what's up
well I just have a question I am already
retired I retired early
and I've had an annuity for since about
2000. and it's worth a certain amount
but I could start taking 12 500 per year
from it now
and my question is should I start taking
that twelve thousand five hundred per
year and doing something with that money
or just leave the money in there which
currently hasn't been uh it's worth
about 190 000. can you do a lump sum
rollover
um
I probably could it's it's it's
categorized as a retirement annuity but
I bought it personally with my own
personal money after tax money
a couple of those years ago I've not
checked into whether I can actually is
this is a fixed annuity so it's paying
like five percent
yeah yeah I think you can do better than
that on two hundred thousand dollars
so if you let's pretend that if you were
in mutual funds you got 10 percent
average and you're making five percent
on 200 000 that's ten thousand dollars a
year you're missing out on
right thousand dollars a month almost
so if I'm you I'm gonna discuss moving
that to a better investment than a five
percent investment
um I don't own any annuities of that
type I'm 62 so I'm retirement age and I
don't own anything like that all of my
money is in good mutual funds in return
in you know IRAs 401ks that kind of
thing so what I would do is just tell
you to go to a Smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com which is an
investment advisor we're not in that
business but we recommend people that
are and
um they can help you they'll teach you
to do it the Ramsey Way and they'll help
you learn about it and you'll get a lot
more comfort and being able to move that
way it's a pretty standard thing for a
teacher give me a quick breakdown what's
an annuity an annuity is a savings
account with an insurance company
oh so they're they're doing this for
them not for us exactly all right
insurance companies uh cannot sell
Investments they're not in the
investment business insurance brokers
insurance agents are life insurance
license they're not Securities licensed
so they they sell if they sell any kind
of an investment it'll fall under the
annuity headline there's two types fixed
and variable affixed is what she had a
lot of teachers haven't that's how I
knew that and most of those are around
five percent that's how I knew that and
uh then there's which those are it's
kind of like buying a CD
they lock him in at five the bank is
making 12 on them and they're keeping
the seven yeah yeah they're making um I
mean life insurance companies are the
largest lenders in the commercial real
estate World wow most your apartment
complexes shopping malls skyscrapers are
financed by life insurance companies the
money came from Whole Life policies and
annuities that you put with them they
pay you a fixed amount they put the
money back out at a higher rate in the
mortgage world is where a lot of it is
and so that's how that's how they make
so much money wow they make a lot more
money on that stuff than they do on the
actual insurance policies yeah so um
kind of follow the money thing and I
wake you up variable annuities however
are okay in certain circumstances I
don't own any but a lot of people do
because that's a mutual fund inside of
an annuity okay and there's a place for
that in some cases so you can look for a
variable annuity if you can't do
anything else at a minimum you need to
roll this to that but maybe you just
need to go do some good investing with
it straight up this is the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personalities my
co-host this hour one of my favorite
people on the planet has just walked in
uh we're so honored to have him in
Nashville today a new book is out Sean
of the South officially known as Sean
Dietrich if you're not reading Sean
Dietrich I I don't know how you know
possibly how to exist in the South one
of the things I discovered going to your
event last night Sean was that we can
actually use your material for training
the people that have moved to Tennessee
or Alabama from California we can train
them how things work wow that's uh I
guess that could be used I'm not sure
how y'all do things with Tennessee
because I'm still kind of falling out
with the football team
well once every 15 years you whiner give
us one give us one I believe we've just
eliminated our Alabama's margin for
error is all we've done
the statistical oh gosh all right let's
get to it there's a new book thank
goodness another book by uh Sean with
the Sean Magic on it You Are My Sunshine
written about a very personal point in
your life where your wife Jamie said
it's time for you to do something big uh
and when Jamie says do something Sean
does it amen smart man happy wife happy
life and so you guys decide you're going
to go on a little Adventure tell us
about it uh yeah we my wife uh had a
cancer scare when we first got married
and it was it was traumatic for us
because uh you know waiting in this
waiting period you have you don't know
what comes next and it's almost worse
than the disease itself and I've heard
that from many people so she made me
make a promise during this period of our
life that I would do something big with
her which was to ride a 350 Mile Trail
through four states and In the Heat of
the Moment I said I'd do it and many
years later the pandemic happened and
I'd forgotten all about this and she
cast in on her promise oh and uh I
really had no choice
in the matter so the Allegheny Trailhead
so is this the Appalachian Trail well it
does ride through the Appalachians but
not never it does cross the Appalachian
Trail of one spot but no it's not the
Appalachian Trail and so you did a you
did bikes right it's a limestone Trail
uh and we rode from Pittsburgh all the
way to Georgetown Virginia
and my groin is still recording it's
gonna say you're still walking with a
limp a little bit yes I'm shorter after
it's all said and done
my Preparation H stock has done really
well and now I know why see this man
knows how
long did this take this took us longer
to complete than it takes most people to
complete veterinary school
we I think it took us about three weeks
and some people complete the trailer in
about a day or two whoa yeah that's
that's pretty beastly okay so this three
weeks had to be uh you had you're a
collector of stories I read your column
every morning and um sometimes I'm
laughing sometimes I'm crying but I
cried in Applebee's commercial so I'm an
easy kid so but not you got me this
morning this morning are you going to be
this morning Sean and I I'm not a crier
like Dave is and man you got me what I
mean I am a crier I I I well the dog
stuff gets me because I'm a dog guy yeah
me too and so man it's just uh and this
new one you got that was abused it's
blind because of her abuse it's crazy
yeah she is she's a real gift uh she's a
real gift to us
so anyway the adventures on the trail
what happened give us some good ones
from the book the book Is You Are My
Sunshine a story of love promises and a
really long bike ride well you know to
to be quite Frank with you uh I've
always been a pretty fearful person that
very very much so actually and I find
that uh getting out here expanded my
boundary just a little bit and it it
helped me get over some of that and so
Jamie and I both were very active now
compared to how we were before this book
before I wrote this book
uh and we're less afraid of a few things
and that sounds pretty melodramatic but
it's true uh just just expanding our
boundary walking outside uh I hate
snakes I hate spiders you're very
intimate with snakes and spiders on the
trail
uh I'm afraid of poison ivy deathly
afraid of poison ivy no longer I mean I
can walk right through it and I know you
know maybe I'm going to go through some
pain or maybe not so uh you know it
happened during a very fearful time the
pandemic was a very fearful time so were
people weird on the trail during that
time yes they very much were uh they
were because of the pandemic because the
pandemic had nothing to do with the
bearded Alabama in their midst it could
have been that it was very strange on
the trail during that period of time
some people had uh they they would hold
their breath as you pass by and other
times they'd you know they had no
problem with it at all yeah the
miniature version there's a three mile
Loop over near my house goes it's a
Wooded Trail that I was doing during
that time with my dog and I'd get out
and do it every morning early because I
got fat and so I was going to do
something get rid of the fat I'm just
we're out there walking every morning
and um there was this couple that would
freak out I would see them every third
morning you know but they would like
walk off into the woods like 50 yards up
into the woods I'm like someone's gonna
bite you and it ain't gonna be a covet
you know it's like wow they were freak I
mean but it's like like I had invaded
their Trail yeah there was a lot of that
there was you we met so many different
people on the trail we really did get a
little snapshot of America I met people
from out west I met people from overseas
and everybody dealt with everything very
differently
so Sean and I met several years ago his
uh book the stars of Alabama had uh came
out in 2019 uh it had in it what I call
Sean magic which is his ability to weave
a story together in a way that grabs you
by the heart the throat the stomach
whatever whatever it needs to to get a
hold of you to make you react uh
world-class Storyteller
um gosh You Are My Sunshine I already
picked up I I just random opened it a
while ago and started reading got down
into the story of the pastor of the
fixture bike when it broke oh yeah you
know I just got sucked into it it's just
like it's uh I can't I can't I'm gonna
have to finish it I'll have to start it
tonight I'll probably finish it by
morning the way I go uh I think I'm
gonna give you a raise for all this
promotion well it's it's good writing it
really is I I I'm not a good writer I'm
really good at marketing but I really
like reading people who know how to
write and this is this is fun well and
I'll tell you I was telling you off air
um I I consider myself like the thing
I'm obsessed about is a good Storyteller
and I was raised in a house with
Garrison Keeler and raised in a house
with Lewis Grizzard and ladies in the
house with my parents really
um uh taught us to curate good
storytelling and my mom's an English
Professor so I I am attuned to Great
writing and is I don't know how you have
the output you do I don't know how you
continually get me to stop in my crazy
busy life and exhale a little bit and so
it becomes this existential gift you
give us every morning just to just to
breathe I mean I can't I can't I read I
can't wait to get into this man can I
come back here every week yeah anytime
you need it you've done more for my
mental health right now
we just we traffic in so much fluff and
then it's it's so refreshing to see an
actual ray of sunshine sit down thank
you next to us and and provide a gift to
all of us man you're great at what you
do thank you thank you so much thank you
I don't know what I'm doing the current
book Is You Are My Sunshine by Sean
Dietrich Sean of the South the story of
he and Jamie's wife taking the Allegheny
Trailhead in Pittsburgh and making it
all the way several hundred miles and
all the stories along the way you will
not want to miss that you will not want
to miss the stars of Alabama and you can
register and sign up for the email
delivery I guess is what I did where is
that where do you get that you might
just have to Google my name okay okay
it's like you got a website yeah yeah
you can find my I should know this I'm
sorry I should too you know but um
anyway it's spelled the CN that's right
s-c-a-n yeah yeah very good stuff so
what was your favorite stop on the trail
my favorite stop would have been uh the
end
it was it was it was long and arduous
and and you can look at me and I'm kind
of built like Herman Munster I I don't
need to be competing in athletics so it
was nice to be done
what's one big takeaway you had uh one
big takeaway would be that you can do a
lot more than you think you can if you
if you if you force yourself to try yeah
and I I love what you said you got out
there and it stretched you and you
didn't return to the same shape now we
hack we hike Jamie and I about three
times a week now before this we would
have never gone out and done anything
like that yeah wow good to see you my
friend I'm so proud of that proud of
your success and uh folks check it out
Sean Dietrich Sean of the South anything
he's writing the new book You Are My
Sunshine you do not want to miss this
writing uh it will I'm getting on a
plane in the morning flying to
California it's gonna make that plane
fly faster that's the way that works
well good to see you my friend thank you
thank you thank you check it out this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
Ramsey so Solutions on the debt free
stage Braden and Tristan are with us hey
guys how are you fantastic good to have
you guys where do y'all live uh Tremont
Utah oh fun welcome to Nashville and how
much debt have you paid off 54 400 good
for you and how long did that take uh
seven and a half months good for you and
your range of income that was about 60
during that time cool what do you all do
for a living I worked for Dominion
Energy natural gas company in Utah uh
pre-construction rep I'm an insurance
specialist for a group of hospitals oh
wow okay cool what kind of debt was your
54. it was our house
no you have a paper you're weird looking
at weird people how old are you how old
are you guys 26 25. goodness you're
insane weird people that's right wow
what's this house worth about 320. of
course it is oh my gosh
I got you and 100 Dead free and
everything 100 yep unbelievable okay
this is a great story already but tell
me how this happened what's your Ramsay
connection how this whole thing come
down yes for sure so uh when I was 19 I
got a truck and went thirty thousand
dollars in debt for it and I started a
new position at a grocery store
um one of my best friends Jace uh
mentioned uh your name to me because I
was talking about the new truck and he
said that you can help us get out of
debt and so I went looked up your
website and YouTube and watched all the
videos and I found Financial Peace
University the uh take home kit so we I
went and ordered that and then me and
Tristan were dating at the time and so I
thought it would be great to take
together so we started taking that
together and uh he's a real romantic
right yeah I got this i got this
financial class we can watch fun date
night oh yeah big time your heart
started beating so fast oh yeah watch it
down in the parents basement
so so yeah we took that class together
um once we started taking the class we
didn't really have a financial
Foundation of what we wanted to do or
what we should do for investing saving
and I want to know how to get out of
debt so we started taking those classes
and you went running across the street
the stage and was yelling intensity and
you got to run that moment like just
changed me uh it lit a fire up under me
and it hasn't gone out since wow same
with trust into so we started working
the plan separate I learned how to
budget do a zero-based budget haven't
missed one since
anyways we got married May of 2016 and
um we I was still in debt with the truck
we were about 21 22 000 left
um so we hit the ground running we know
what we were going to do we did some
mock budgets before we got married
um and uh that December we um paid the
truck off which was amazing and then um
when we were dating and engaged we made
a crazy goal to bring our first child
into we wanted to bring our first child
into a paid for home it's just something
we both felt very strongly about and uh
so we started working that plan we got
we paid off the truck we got our
emergency fund I'm fully funded then
from 2017 the summer of 2017 to October
2021 four years we in baby step 3B we
were just renting it was cheap rent the
whole time so we stacked up we we paid
173 000 for our down payment
I feel like I'm in The Matrix Man like
yeah uh I don't know we were just
gazelle intense we didn't stop we just
kept going there's a big difference 73
down yeah and then you knocked the other
54 out that's correct yep meanwhile it
goes up in value yes it did Big Time
yeah and so fast forward to today baby
on the way baby on the way baby girl
January
yep all right the story is just like
they had a plan or something I didn't I
didn't know what day it was for most of
my 19th of the year I was 19. and to
think man good for you dude thank you so
much and what did you say your your
salary has been this whole time uh right
now we're about 110 but during that is
about 60 or so
wow you gotta you got to make a million
dollars a year to pay off your house man
uh yeah seriously right
how many people told you that everything
you were doing wouldn't work oh like a
lot so many yeah so many people most
people yeah how do you keep going with
everybody telling you it's not gonna
work is there a y right here our little
girl yep we didn't even know she was
coming but she was our plan the whole
time so bro she's never gonna know what
you went through no she's not she's
gonna know two parents who just smile a
lot that's right and crack up when the
roof leaks that's right
unbelievable man
man that's just well done you guys very
very well done you're powerful couple
thank you so much very powerful you are
well on your way you're going to be so
wealthy and so generous and uh you have
truly strained your family tree because
you're working at a grocery store at 19
years old and a guy says you paid what
for a truck you need to eat this Ramsay
stuff yep that's right and here we go we
end up with Financial Peace University
as our date night
wow hey man it keeps kids from making
out that's for sure
hey so hey y'all don't come from money
is this new for both of your both of you
yeah
or this level of discussion
intentionality for sure yes yeah I'm
just just watching you too it looks like
this is New Look it's like y'all have
created something out of I mean y'all
took machetes and headed off into the
jungle and cut your own New Path that's
right made it happen
but family proud of you that you're oh
yeah yes for sure yeah they got to be
standing back going wow yeah yeah
they've been awesome yeah that's good
good for you all right so you're exactly
how old again I'm 26 and 25. maybe
January 4th yep 350 000 paid for house
100 debt free
making 110 so millionaires by probably
31 if the income doesn't change
dramatically up and it's likely to is
the trend in these situations so it
might be 30. but um and depending on how
fast the house goes up to that'll affect
it but that's probably 30 31 somewhere
around in there wow look at them they're
both not be like yeah Dave it's in our
expression here we know we kind of
already run these numbers Dave we have a
spreadsheet at home
we know yeah this is a pretty Pretty
stinking cool all right what do you tell
people the key
to be to being here where you are
absolutely budgeting after you have to
do it but um being on the same page with
your spouse you can't you can't do it if
you're not on the same page you don't
have the same goals how many times did
you argue
about about money about money yeah uh we
really haven't had a money fight we
really haven't we've always been on the
same page same goal it's made it so much
so much easier and it's made our
marriage just so much and nothing's
gonna get in the way of the goal exactly
no I want to go on a trip it's you know
well we got to go that's right exactly
yep that's right and we can go on a trip
anywhere we want to go by God so what's
the first big thing you're gonna do with
money now
um we already went to Hawaii
yeah now we're just saving for our baby
so
oh my gosh
the number of times 18 to 19 and 20 year
olds have asked me like what do I need
to be doing right now and over the last
few years my answer has shifted to work
like mad because you're going to open
your eyes and be 25 26 27 and that 25 26
27 year old you is going to be really
glad you didn't go to the bar and you
took another shift and you didn't buy
something stupid and you put some money
in savings and y'all are walking
testimony to the truth
unbelievable you too thank you so much
you're inspiring me man an old man
you're inspiring me I'm grateful for you
thank you well you guys are why we come
down here and do this we're so proud
thank you very well so much absolutely
Rose we got the live and give bundle for
you which is The Total Money Makeover
book for you to give away and Inspire
someone your lives are doing that but
this will help you as well the uh baby
steps millionaires book because you are
on your way that's your next chapter for
sure Financial Peace University one year
membership again you've been through it
so you'll be giving that away I would
imagine but whatever you want to do it's
to live and give bundle enjoy it very
very well done Braden and Tristan from
Utah wow 54 000 paid off in seven and a
half months that's house in every
now let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
wow moms and dads if you got a 16 year
old and you could turn them into one of
those you're a good parent this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Luke 12 6-7
what is the price of five sparrows two
copper coins
yet God does not forget a single one of
them
and the Very hairs on your head are all
numbered Renee Brown says worthiness
does not have prerequisites
you're a big brene brown fan aren't you
John yeah she said she's a smart
houstonian oh really yep
and James from my neck of the woods
there yeah James is with us up next in
Detroit hey James what's up
uh not much just uh trying to get some
advice cool how can we help all right
well I owe my parents fifty thousand
dollars I'm happily willing to pay it
all back the faster the better now I
work for one of the big three auto
manufacturers and I make about a hundred
thousand dollars a year and next year
we're expecting a strike
so I'm wondering do I pause baby step
two to build up a strike fund in order
to weather that storm and then after
that to immediately give them everything
I have down to my last thousand and then
get a loan to cover everything that's
left
uh
how long you been there
um at GM sorry is that the auto
manufacturer or the big three yeah I
guess it's not hard to narrow it down
but I mean yeah go ahead how long have
you been with GM
seven years okay all right
uh you know how to strike during that
time I don't think have you
uh just the last contract oh there was
the last contract when was that
four years ago so you did strike four
years ago yeah for how long
it was about two and a half months three
months really I missed that okay
all right
so
um
given the current environment and your
seven years of experience what is your
prediction
on this strike that comes up next year
um would you say it's a 50 50 chance
a 10 chance that you strike what would
you guess
and I can't really no I mean you have I
know it's a guess I said gas well it's
your guess based on what you know
because I don't have one
I'd say it's more likely than not seen
as this is the best labor market for the
worker we've had in decades so you think
it's greater than a 50 chance
yeah then yes I would stop everything
and I would pile up cash
all right and then the day end of the
day you get a contract a new contract
signed and the storm Blows By you write
Mom and Dad a check
and my goal would be to have enough cash
to just pay them off
yeah and that's what I'm saying if I
don't have enough get a loan so I owe
the bank and not my parents yeah I don't
think you're going to have a contract
for at least a year
yeah and if you're going to do this this
is not an excuse to go spend money it's
an excuse to not work the debt snowball
today and not not be on The Total Money
Makeover baby steps today but instead
Push pause and pile up a huge storm fund
as with the same intensity you would be
using to pay off the debt and so I'm
guessing in one year you're gonna have
50 Grand
because you're going to work extra
you're going to live on you're gonna
take all the OT you can get you're going
to do everything you can get to get
extra money in you're gonna live on
nothing and you're going to pile up cash
like you were getting out of debt
instead you're gonna have a pile of it
so I my goal would be to say when the
contract is signed we write Mom and Dad
check
all right let's make that the goal if
you're going to pause and if you got a
greater than 50 chance of something
happening uh and that's not based on
drama that's based on you know your
experience of what's out there what
happened four years ago or four and a
half years ago
um you're you know you're looking at
you're working in the middle of all this
every day you've got more of a sense of
it than I do I really don't know what's
going to happen with I don't have any
clue I don't even have a good hint so
I'm going to go with you on that but I
yeah I would just do that but let's have
the gold clearing it if you're gonna if
you're gonna pull that if you're gonna
make that move yeah that's that's my
that's my one caution man it's gonna
that's gonna be hard not to spend that
money piled up in an account exactly be
diligent Steve is with us Steve is in
Pensacola hi Steve how are you
I'm better than I deserve Dave how are
you just the same how can I help
um thanks Dave and John for taking my
call I'm 73 years old my wife is 71
years old we are completely debt free
household income of 70 000 that includes
uh an adjunct teaching position as well
as Social Security
um we have not purchased uh funeral
arrangements for ourselves do you
recommend that we do it so our children
don't have to take care of it and if so
pay all at once or do it over uh time
maybe you should you can do it both of
our parents did it it saved us a lot of
heartache when they passed away a couple
years ago
okay
um I would invest the money that you
would pay for this instead of giving it
to them okay because the inflation rate
of funeral items is around the normal
inflation rate so around four percent
normally I don't know how much inflation
in this current inflationary Market is
at the funeral world but I don't pre-pay
anything but I would set the money aside
and so go into the funeral home
completely pre-plan every detail
have a file at your house with every
detail in it and a file at the funeral
home with every detail in it so that
they don't have to make any decisions
and have a savings account over at the
bank uh that has that exact amount of
money in it and tell them where that is
and tell them where the file is and if
something happens to you they walk in
and get the file out and use the money
if you put the money in a mutual fund
that's fine that's what I've done uh and
uh but the pre what we have told people
from for the last 30 years is pre-plan
with as much detail as you think is
going to give Comfort to your family in
your case sounds like a lot of detail
and then do not pre-pay
all right
that's the plan that we use
um
do you did you specify in your will
where you want to be buried or do you
care
I am not in the will okay left that
alone
um and uh you know what that's all
shifted around and I I you just caught
me I don't think I've addressed that in
the in the file yeah yeah the Ramsay
file there's a lot of other stuff
covered but I've got some friends of
mine that are very specific I want to be
buried in this place in this particular
home and then I I mean for me I don't I
don't care it's not that I won't be here
I'm not I'm not worried about it uh but
it is comforting
the more indecisions are already made
that's right the less the people behind
have struggle while they're grieving
right well and there's always the one
cousin that thinks Dave should be back
here in East Tennessee and somebody
wants him in Nashville and someone wants
to be frank Sophia
um yeah and uh you know I always really
like the lake it's exactly what what
yeah but that I'm not there so but yeah
it's it's a thing so yeah he's right
though when his mom and dad passed the
fact that it was prepaid and pre-planned
they just walked in and it was all done
trying to paperwork is done it was all
set up and it is it is
um
you know death is enough there's enough
grief and sometimes even trauma around
death to have everything to not have
that on you is a big relief time yeah
yeah so anything you can do to pre-plan
we're all for it but I've talked to
people that were 40 years old their dad
died or their grandpa died and it was a
mess so they end up in the funeral home
two weeks later and give the guy six or
eight thousand bucks or ten thousand
twelve thousand fifteen thousand bucks
whatever it is to prepay and pre-plan
and if you put that fifteen thousand in
at 40 years old and leave it till you're
80 it's like a million dollars who are
you King Tut you know you don't want to
you don't wanna do that that's what
prepaying does now in his case 73 I
don't know his life expectancy is
necessarily I didn't ask for details but
um you know I guess normal would be well
you've already he's there so but the uh
uh but you know if you got 10 years
money's not gonna grow as much there you
go if you're 73 is when you're 40 but
still uh I would set that in an
investment I don't have a funeral fund
in mind I've just got money that they
can the family can access obviously to
cover it but the actual
um you know I at one time I had it all
detailed out and it shifted and moved
and I should go back and redo that it
doesn't take that long to sit and think
about it and write it down oh sure and
stick it in the file with the will
that's right you know it changes people
I think it's a healthy exercise too but
yeah hey be sure and check out all the
deals at ramseysolutions.com at ten
dollars right now including Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment you do
not want to miss taking that I took it
the other day it's life-changing it's
good stuff Dr John deloney good show
today thank you well done James Andrews
Zach Ben and Austin in the booth the
booth dudes who did it again I'm Dave
Ramsey we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18
[Music]
the Ramsay show every week a lot of
those people listen on one of our 600
plus radio stations across the country
to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]